have you seen the sales figures of evita
they're pretty terrible and I have no
idea why it's easily my most used system
heck even when I'm sitting at home I'm
more likely to attempt another hell run
and spelunky or fortify my home base in
Terraria and then flip on a console
clearly I'm almost alone in my love for
the Vita I'm gonna tell you why this
should be atop your need to buy list
this year you know it seems to earth
people about the Vitas incredible
catalog ports yes almost every game on
the system originated elsewhere but what
so many view is a problem I see is a
huge advantage why would I be upset that
I can play lone survivor no matter where
I am or that I can relive the gripping
Thomas was alone of course there are
some exclusives tearaway is an endearing
arts-and-crafts adventure that is almost
too adorable if that's possible and
danganronpa may be difficult to say but
Boyd is a tell a good story and then
there's persona 4 golden which became my
favorite RPG ever halfway through the
game the Vita can play Sony's expansive
back catalog Chrono Trigger Metal Gear
Solid Final Fantasy Tactics you get the
picture there is never a moment when I'm
left warming what I should play next
there are plenty of new games planned
for the future too I'm super excited for
rogue legacy in la mulana even though
they're just ports you can throw the
binding of isaac rebirth in that list
too the more ports the better as long as
they're great that are also original
games such as a mathematics Mindbender
metric oh and the super stealthy volume
do you want even more stealth counter
spy looks pretty darn neat from what
I've seen of all the upcoming games
nothing excites me more than Starbound
I'll leave you with one more game before
moving on persona 4 dancing all night I
can never say no to a rhythm game I
don't care about specs at all but I do
know the Vita is powerful have you seen
Killzone mercenary it looks just as good
as its ps3 counterparts but the best
thing about the Vitas hardware is how
flexible it is which is why you see so
may
great games hit the digital store
shelves plus with a touchscreen back
touch camera microphone and two analog
sticks just about any type of game can
find a home on the Vita the Vita also
has great complementary features to the
core games PlayStation Plus gives great
deals on the best and newest games
including free games every week it's a
steal for $50 a year remote plays
seamlessly streams your PlayStation 4
games to your Vita perfect from when
your television is commandeered by
another family member and if you still
want more games PlayStation now lets you
stream Sony's extensive back catalogue
right to your console have I sold you on
the system yet no well just remember
it's better on Vita isn't just a slogan
I made up it's the truth